hi herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid ihr habt es
sicher schon mitbekommen in der Nacht
zum Montag sind in Libyen in Nordafrika
durch massive Regenfälle 2 Staudämme
gebrochen und haben für ziemlich schwere
Überflutungen gesorgt ganze Teile der
Hafenstadt wurden ins Meer gespült nach
Angaben der internationalen Organisation
für Migration sind mehr als 3000
Menschen 30.000 Menschen dadurch
obdachlos geworden alleine in der
Hafenstadt der tausende werden vermisst
und von mehr als 5.300 Toten wird
gesprochen wir wollen heute bei ZDF
heute live einen Blick nach Libyen
werfen und mit Menschen sprechen die vor
Ort sind also für euch die Lage vor Ort
einordnen und das tun wir zum einen mit
unserer Korrespondentin für die Region
mit goldener atai in Kairo in Ägypten
wir sprechen mit talals er ist von der
NGO international medical Corps für uns
am Start wir sprechen mit dem Libyen
Experten Thomas Volk von der Konrad
Adenauer
Stiftung und mit baschier Ben Amir er
leitet die pharmazeutik-abteilung vom
International rescue commenty in
tripolist lasst uns aber erstmal einen
Blick auf die aktuellen Bilder werfen
mittlerweile ist nämlich die
internationale Hilfe in Libyen
angelaufen und das auch aus Europa hier
seht ihr gerade wie Feuerwehrleute auf
Italien eine Maschine mit rettungs- und
Hilfsgütern beladen die Türkei hatte
bereits gestern Hilfe losgeschickt es
sind doch schon erste konvoys im
Katastrophengebiet unterwegs die
versuchen mit diesen Converse die da
gerade seht in orange die Leute dort vor
Ort zu erreichen und das wird aber durch
die Wassermassen und die dadurch
größtenteils zerstörte Infrastruktur
erschwert und parallel läuft auch die
Suche nach vermisstenweite einige
Menschen konnten schon aus den Fluten
gerettet werden wie ihr gerade gesehen
habt ja und mit Rettern vor Ort mit
helfenden vor Ort wollen wir auch heute
sprechen wenn ihr fragen habt an unsere
Gäste oder einfach eure Meinung zum
Thema mit uns Teil wird dann tut das wie
immer gerne hier im Youtube Chat oder an
die hier eingeblendete Mailadresse und
jetzt spreche ich aber direkt mal
jemanden mit jemanden vor Ort und zwar
mit talboa nass er ist von der NGO
international medical Corps und uns
jetzt live aus Libyen zugeschaltet guten
Abend schön dass Sie bei uns sind
guten Abend vielen Dank
Herr bonas wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe sind sie aktuell
ungefähr 20 Kilometer vor der
Küstenstadt Bengasi das ist etwa 300
Kilometer entfernt von Dada also von der
Stadt die besonders stark betroffen ist
wie erleben sie denn gerade ganz aktuell
die Situation in der betroffenen Region
die Situation in der Region ist
natürlich katastrophal
die Leute hier sind natürlich am Boden
zerstört sie haben ihre Verwandten
verloren sie machen sich große Sorgen
sie wissen nicht genau wie es mit der
Zukunft aussieht
und ihre Verwandten sind teilweise
vermisst und jeder sucht praktisch nach
Hilfe und Unterstützung besonders in der
Stadt drin und trotz der großen
Anstrengungen der
Kommunalbehörden und auch
mit der Hilfe
internationaler Hilfskräfte
gibt es natürlich etwas Unterstützung
aber man braucht noch mehr Unterstützung
wenn man mit dem Menschen spricht
wenn man mit Leuten von der
Stadtregierung spricht oder Leuten aus
der Gegend die besonders betroffen ist
das sagen die dass die ganz dringend
bestimmte Hilfsgüter brauchen also alle
Arten von Hilfsgütern praktisch
sie arbeiten ja selbst bei einer NGO für
eine NGO welche Aufgabe wird Ihre
Organisation denn ganz konkret vor Ort
übernehmen also welche Hilfe und wie
läuft das bisher an bzw was sind die
Hindernisse dieser Hilfe
so ähm also
als international America in Libyen
wollen wir natürlich
also zusammen auch mit den lokalen
Helfern und den lokalen Behörden wir
wollen wir wollen natürlich die lokalen
Behörden unterstützen
zunächst mal müssen wir Situationen
einschätzen um sicherzustellen dass
unsere Hilfe auch in die richtige Hilfe
geht und dass das auch mit dem
übereinstimmt was eben die Strategie der
Lokalbehörden ist
und wir fangen jetzt erstmal damit an
dass wir uns die wichtigsten Dinge
anschauen die gerade benötigt werden in
den Gemeinden und Zusammenhang mit den
Behörden und wir schauen uns an wie wir
ein medizinisches Notfall-Team schicken
können um so ein feldhospital zu
unterstützen dass von den typischen
Behörden innerhalb der Stadt Dana
betrieben wird
jetzt ist ja Libyen ein Land das
politisch zweigeteilt ist es sind auch
schon 48 Stunden vergangen erstmal ohne
das eine Ersthelfer ankam inwiefern
behindert denn diese politische
Zweiteilung des Landes die aktuellen
Hilfsmaßnahmen
[Musik]
also eigentlich haben wir im ganzen Land
Bemühungen gesehen wir
sehen das Unterstützung gibt von allen
Regionen ob in Tripoli oder
verschiedenen Städten
und hier in
Bengasi ich komme aus Tripoli und ich
bin jetzt auf meinem Weg nach Bengasi im
Osten und ich sehe immer wieder das
unterschiedliche Gruppen hier nach Dana
fahren um dort
Ausrüstung zu spenden oder Hilfsgüter zu
bringen
oder auch als freiwillige mitzuhelfen
bei den Suchmaßnahmen in der Stadt und
bei den Hilfsmaßnahmen also jeder hier
im Lande
in allen Regionen
versucht seinen Beitrag zu leisten und
die Menschen Indianer zu unterstützen
während dieser schwierigen Zeit
und vielleicht abschließend noch die
Frage was sind das für Menschen die dort
vor Ort aktuell auf Ihre Hilfe
angewiesen sind was sind das für
Menschen die Hilfe benötigen und welche
Gruppen sind vielleicht besonders
betroffen und hilfsbedürftig
wir können natürlich die Menschen die
Hilfe benötigen aufteilen in
verschiedene Gruppen
zum Beispiel
diejenigen die immer noch
in der Stadt drin sind die nicht
rauskommen das wäre eine Gruppe und da
gibt es natürlich diejenigen die
praktisch Binnenflüchtlinge geworden
sind weil sie kein Zuhause mehr haben
dazu gehören auch sehr Betroffene
Gruppen oder verwundbare Gruppen wie
Frauen und Kinder oder Menschen die
behindert sind zum Beispiel
und die sind praktisch auch im Zentrum
unseres Programms auf die konzentrieren
wir uns auch sehr als international
medical core in Libyen
vielen Dank für Ihre Eindrücke von vor
Ort und wir wünschen Ihnen hier alles
Gute nach Libyen für die nächsten Tage
und Wochen
ich danke ihnen vielen Dank dass ich zu
Ihnen sprechen konnte schönen Abend noch
ja und von dieser live vor Ort Erfahrung
eines Menschen der sich in einer NGO
engagiert den Menschen vor Ort hilft
schalten wir jetzt einmal nach Kairo in
Ägypten zur unserer Korrespondentin für
diese Region nämlich zur goldene atai
hallo schönen Abend
hallo guten Abend
was hast du denn bisher gehört aus der
Krisenregion was sind deine Berichte
deine Erfahrung von den du gehört hast
uns erreichen seit der vergangenen Nacht
sehr viele Augenzeugen Berichte und
viele Helfer erzählen dass viele
Menschen gerade auch in Dürener so
traumatisiert sein dass sie nicht mehr
weinen können sie haben etwas erlebt
dass ihre Vorstellungskraft gesprengt
hat eine Katastrophe ungeahnten Ausmaßes
mit
Opferzahlen die alles bisher Erlebte im
jahrelangen libyschen Bürgerkrieg auch
in den Schatten stellen die Opferzahlen
befürchten viele Helfer könnten weitaus
höher sein denn es sind wirklich ganze
Familien weggeschwemmt worden es gibt
aus diesen Familien also niemanden der
irgendwie vermisste melden könnte und
aus den Berichten die uns erreichen ist
doch immer wieder sehr viel gut
herauszuhören über die sehr verzögerte
Reaktion der Behörden der das nichts tun
das Staates eigentlich es ist sehr viel
Wut auf die eigene Regierung auch
herauszuhören die im Moment wohl so
hören wir alles dransetzen um die Bürger
zu überwachen damit dieser
Unmut nicht zu groß wird die aber in den
vergangenen 48 Stunden sehr wenig getan
hat was aktive Hilfsmaßnahmen angeht
ja Fassungslosigkeit und Wut also was
ist denn dein Eindruck was wird aktuell
von den Menschen vor Ort am meisten
benötigt welche konkrete Hilfe
also was wir immer wieder hören sind
Rettungsteams die Leichenbergen dann
natürlich Sanitäter Krankenwagen
Helikopter diese Helikopter sind dann
reichlich verspätet
zur Verfügung gestellt worden aber von
der ägyptischen Regierung
viele ägyptische Arbeitsmigranten Leben
in dieser Region in Ost Libyen und die
haben sich dann Hilfe suchen
verzweifelt an ihre eigene Regierung
gewandt es fehlen so grundlegende Dinge
wie Leichensäcke es fehlen Särge also
viele mussten in oder werden immer noch
in Massengräbern verscharrt es fehlen
mobile Krankenhäuser das haben wir auch
eben gerade auch gehört und die
Überlebenden jetzt die auf den
straßenhausen den vielen den fehlt etwas
zu essen den fehlt etwas zu trinken weil
viele Geschäfte in dieser wasserschneise
waren und von den Fluten weggeschwemmt
wurden
danke für deine Eindrücke aus Kairo und
schönen Abend noch
ja und Collie hat auch ein Stück hat
heute an einem Stück gearbeitet was die
aktuelle Lage heute am Mittwoch noch mal
zusammenfasst lass uns da mal
reinschauen
in Ost Libyen einst berühmt für weiß
getünchte Häuser und Palmengärten der
Jahrhundertsturm hat zwei
staudämmebersten lassen und vier Brücken
zerstört die 100.000 seelenstadt ist nur
schwer erreichbar
einwohnererzählen die Infrastruktur sei
seit Jahren vernachlässigt und die
Region den Fluten regelrecht
ausgeliefert worden wir warten die
Behörden seit letzter Woche nein seit
Jahren dass der Dame Risse hat dass der
Damm gewartet werden muss wir sagten es
und niemand hörte auf uns und jetzt ist
ganz Dana überschwemmt
hunderte Leichen liegen vor und in den
Krankenhäusern der Stadt sie können
keine verletzt mehr aufnehmen ganze
Familien verschwanden in sieben Meter
hohen Welle
die Wut über die ausbleibende Hilfe ist
spürbar der Bürgermeister der
Nachbargemeinde wird deutlich
nichts funktioniert hier keine
staatlichen Dienste nichts schaut
endlich hin und tut was wir erfahren
hier ein großes Unrecht
das nichts funktioniert ist auch die
Folge von vielen Jahren Krieg und
Korruption im Land jetzt senden die
Einwohner Hilfe an die ganze Welt
die Lage in der ist extrem tragisch der
libysche Rote Halbmond und der Staat
können das nicht allein bewältigen
eine Region so groß wie Sachsen-Anhalt
ist überflutet niemand war vorgewarnt
niemand wurde rechtzeitig evakuiert
ja viel Wut auch Vorahnung in der
Bevölkerung und sehr eindrückliche
Bilder von goldene atai und jetzt wollen
wir noch mal mit jemandem sprechen der
für uns live vor Ort ist und zwar
sprechen wir jetzt mit Basche Ben Ahmet
er leitet die Pharmazeutik vom
International rescue Comedy in Tripolis
also in der Hauptstadt Libyens und er
ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet guten Abend
guten Abend
was ist aus ihrer Sicht das was die
Menschen in den Katastrophengebieten
gerade ganz konkret brauchen und wie
wollen Sie mit Ihrer Organisation dort
helfen
also es gibt ganz große Bedürfnisse
sprechen wir mal über die
Obdachlosigkeit der Leute haben ihrer
Häuser verloren und es gibt keinen
Zugang zur Stadt da gab es sowohl von
West als auf den Osten Zugangspunkte in
die Stadt jetzt nach dem Zusammenbruch
dieser Verbindungen
ist es ganz schwierig es gibt nur noch
einen Zugangsweg vom Süden aus um nach
der Nacht zu kommen
das reicht natürlich nicht wir haben
10.000 Menschen die vermisst werden
und da gibt's 3000 Menschen von denen
wir wissen dass sie tot sind die Zahlen
gehen hoch
und jede Stunde gehen die Zahlen hoch
die Sucht Teams des Roten Halbmonds
arbeiten Tag und Nacht und finden immer
mehr Leichen
und das gleiche gilt auch für die
Regierung die versuchen jetzt natürlich
den Menschen Hilfe zu geben
[Musik]
und im Moment konzentriert man sich
darauf die Leute zu retten und
aufzufinden und dann natürlich erst die
Hilfe für die Überlebenden anzubieten
und wir müssen natürlich auch die
Leichen bergen unglücklicherweise
das internationale
rescue-komitee und anderer
Organisationen
versuchen dir zu helfen
um effektiv auf die auf das Desaster zu
reagieren die Bevölkerung ist völlig
unter Schock
und viele sind gestorben
oder werden sterben ohne Hilfe viele
haben ihre Angehörigen verloren viele
kommen aus den Gasi
daran dass du mit entfernt die waren
nicht in der Lage mit ihren Verwandten
in der Nacht zu sprechen war das keine
Telekommunikation gab und die suchen
alle nach ihren Angehörigen
und das ist das was im Moment passiert
und
diese Situation
bewerten wir immer wieder und wir aber
ein Tag und Nacht versuchen so gut wie
möglich zu helfen
jetzt leiten sie in ihrer NGO ja das
Pharmazeutik Team sind also Experte für
medizinische Fragen was sind denn gerade
ganz konkret die medizinischen Gefahren
für die Menschen die dort jetzt in
diesem Katastrophengebiet noch leben man
liest ja zum Beispiel immer wieder von
einer solchen Gefahr
im Moment ist es vielleicht noch ein
bisschen früh über solchen zu sprechen
wir müssen wirklich ganz genau
hinschauen was da im Moment passiert
natürlich gibt es Leichen überall
und
deswegen
kümmert sich der Rote Halbmond auch drum
diese Leichen zu bergen damit dadurch
kann der solchen aufkommen aber es ist
einfach noch zu früh über die
Verbreitung von Infektionskrankheiten zu
sprechen wir werden lebensrettende Hilfe
bieten und unsere Teams werden die
Situation bewerten und beobachten
und wenn notwendig werden wir die
Intervention
verstärken zum Teil
helfen wir jetzt Moment dass wir
sanitäre Hilfsgüter liefern
und das ist ganz wichtig in diesem
Zusammenhang
wir haben 35.000 Menschen die ganz
dringend ein Obdach brauchen die
brauchen irgendwie ein Dach überm Kopf
auch die Kinder
die brauchen Hilfe und medizinische
Hilfe dann brauchen wir psychosoziale
Unterstützung
und Erste Hilfe natürlich
und das ist jetzt die Zeit wo wir noch
das Zeitfenster haben wo wir diese
Ersthilfe bieten können
für die Menschen die praktische kann
Obdach mehr haben der alles verloren
haben
sie werden mit ihm voraussichtlich
morgen nach der Donner Reisen also in
die Hafenstadt die so besonders
betroffen ist damit sich unsere
Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen das besser
vorstellen können wie groß ist denn
dieses Team mit dem sie da morgen
hinreisen
wir haben ein großes Team von mehr als
100 Leuten die an den Suchmaßnahmen
teilnehmen
und 18 Leute mit
verschiedenen speziellen Fähigkeiten die
kommen aus Bengasi im Osten
und bengazis praktisch jetzt so der
Knotenpunkt wo wir praktisch die
Hilfsmaßnahmen koordinieren
zusammen mit den Behörden dort
und wir wollen jetzt interne auch etwas
tun und wir sind sehr stark vertreten in
Libyen im Osten Süden und auch im Westen
und wir haben eine Außenstelle
dort 100 km entfernt von Werner vom
voraus wer arbeiten das ist ganz wichtig
für uns dann können wir nämlich
schneller Zugang finden in die Stadt
und
wir werden sicherstellen dass
die Straßen so aufbereitet werden dass
wir dann so schnell wie möglich auch
Hilfe leisten können und vor Ort bringen
können
ja und dabei wünschen wir Ihnen hier
alles alles Gute und viel Erfolg nach
Libyen Herr armiert vielen vielen Dank
dass Sie bei uns waren
ich danke ihnen vielen Dank
ja jetzt trifft diese Katastrophe in
Libyen auf ein Land das eh schon von
schweren Bedingungen von schwierigen
Strukturen geprägt ist das zum einen der
Bürgerkrieg der von 2014 bis 2020
anhielt und der brach damals aus nachdem
Diktator Muhammad al Gaddafi 2011 von
Aufständischen und auch dank einer
militärischen Intervention westlicher
Länder gestürzt wurde damit sehr viel
aber damals auch quasi die komplette
politische Struktur des Landes und
mittlerweile wird das Land quasi von
zwei rivalisierenden Regierungen regiert
deswegen sprechen wir hier auch die
ganze Zeit über den Osten und den Westen
die werden quasi getrennt regiert was
ist damit auf sich hat und inwiefern in
diese komplizierte politische Lage auch
dafür verantwortlich ist dass diese
Katastrophe das Land jetzt so hart
trifft darüber sprechen mit meinem
nächsten Gast dem libyenexperten Thomas
Volk von der Konrad Adenauer Stiftung
der uns jetzt live zugeschaltet das aus
tun ist hallo Herr Volk
guten Abend
Herr folgt die betroffene Stadt die
liegt ja im östlichen Teil des Landes
das haben wir jetzt schon ein paar mal
gehört und der wird von einer anderen
Regierung regiert als der westliche Teil
können Sie die vielleicht für uns kurz
charakterisieren wie müssen wir uns das
vorstellen
genau diese Katastrophe trifft ein
institutionell zwei gespaltenes Land
dass ich zudem in einer politischen
Legitimationskrise befindet wir haben im
Westen Libyens die international
anerkannte Regierung der sogenannten
nationalen Einheit die ja aus einem
UN-Prozess
2021 hervorging und seitdem vor allem
den Westen um Tripolis regiert und im
Osten seit dem Frühjahr 2020 eine
Parallelregierung die also diese
Regierung der nationalen Einheit nicht
anerkennt die sogenannte Regierung der
nationalen Stabilität diese Regierung
wurde anfangs vor allem von Russland
anerkannt wurde von den wagner-söldnern
unterstützt
und kontrolliert im Grunde die Gebiete
in ostblut in wir haben heute also die
paradoxe Situation dass die
international anerkannte Regierung die
intropolis sitzt mit ihrem
Premierminister abdelah mit der BayWa
überhaupt nicht in der Lage wäre nach
Ost Libyen zu kommen und den ostl Libyen
regiert im Grunde eine Regierung die von
warlord-halle verhafter gestützt wird
und die eine fassadenregierung darstellt
sie hat überhaupt keine Bürokratie die
im Grunde auch in der Lage wäre diese
große Katastrophe zu managen daher ist
internationale Unterstützung so wichtig
und wir sagen in ihrem Beitrag zu
vorbereitet die ansteigende
Unruhe in der Gesellschaft das
ungemachtes aufkommt ob der tatsächlich
eine Inkompetenz der australierung
zu diesem Thema haben wir auch direkt
mal eine Frage aus der Community an sie
und zwar fragt jemand auf Youtube wie
ist denn die Zusammenarbeit der
Regierung hat im Osten mit der anderen
Regierung Libyens jetzt vielleicht auch
bezogen auf die Katastrophenhilfe wie
gut funktioniert da eine Koordination
aktuell
es gibt im Grunde keine tatsächlich
abgestimmte Koordination der beiden
Regierungen es geht vor allem darum dass
natürlich jetzt internationale Hilfe
organisiert wird die müsste im Grunde
mit der international anerkannten
Regierungen Tripolis abgestimmt sein
zeitgleich kamen aber auch schon
Hilfsgüter zum Beispiel von der Türkei
oder natürlich von Ägypten die auch in
Ost Libyen ankommen konnten das große
Problem ist dass wir im Grunde ein
machtwagen um derzeit in Libyen haben
die für 2021 geplanten Parlament zu
Präsidentschaftswahlen fanden nicht
statt generell fanden seit 2014 in
Libyen keine Parlamentswahlen mehr statt
und daher war es in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten dringend diskutiert wurden
wieder unter unvermittlung nun eine
politische Lösung sowie der Herstellung
der nationalen Einheit in lübingen
gefunden werden konnte bisher ohne
Ergebnis und inmitten dieser offenen
politischen Krise kam nun diese
Flutkatastrophe die natürlich auch damit
zu tun hatte dass diese beiden Dämme um
der
einstürzten rissen auch weil überhaupt
keine Instandhaltung in den letzten zehn
Jahren stattfand
ja und damit ist auch die nächste Frage
aus der Community beantwortet die hat
nämlich gerade jemand gefragt wieso sind
die Dämme gebrochen das hatten wir auch
im Beitrag gesehen da habt hat auch ein
Bewohner der Stadt
beanstaltet dass die ewig nicht gewartet
wurden und da bereits Risse zu sehen
waren lassen sie uns vielleicht gleich
mal bei der Stadt Wittenau bleiben die
ist ja gerade das Zentrum der
Katastrophe was ist das für eine Stadt
wir müssen uns die vorstellen und welche
politische Prägung hatte sie jetzt bis
zu dieser Katastrophe
liegt zwischen den beiden wichtigen
auslöwischen Städten Bengasi und toprock
hatte um die 100000 Einwohner und das
Ausmaß der Katastrophe wird deutlich
wenn man sich vor Augen führt dass
mindestens ein zehnt und die Zahlen
werden wahrscheinlich noch deutlich nach
oben gehen der Bevölkerung tot oder
vermisst sind dass ein Viertel dieser
Stadt komplett zerstört ist durch die
Wucht der Wassermassen ganze Familien
und eben auch Gebäude entrissen und ins
Meer gespült wurden und diese Stadt hat
allerdings auch historisch eine
bestimmte Relevanz in Libyen nach 2011
nach dem Stuttgarter ist als die
zeitweise hat für Islamisten und bereits
während des libischen Bürgerkrieges vor
allem
2018/2019 wurde die Stadt stark in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen auch durch
Kämpfe und seitdem nicht wirklich wieder
aufgebaut und der in Ost Libyen
herrschende fallout-kali verhafter ist
auch bekannt dafür dass er diese Stadt
eher vernachlässigte und ihr keine
besondere Aufmerksamkeit zukommen ließ
und das sieht man jetzt erst recht sich
in dem auch diese beiden entscheidenden
Staudämme nicht gewartet wurden und
jetzt den Wassermassen durch diesen
starken
Regenfall und durch den Sturm nicht
standhilfen brachen und zu dieser
Tragödie führten
ja Staudämme die nicht gewartet wurden
und jetzt sehr verheerenden Auswirkungen
gibt es noch andere Dinge die in dieser
Stadt in dieser Region in den letzten
Jahren nicht passiert sind die jetzt
halt zum Tragen kommen
man muss sich vor Augen führen dass die
ostlubische Regierung nicht in der Lage
ist für die wesentlichen
Nachfrage der Bevölkerung zu sorgen es
geht im Grunde vor allem darum den
Einfluss der international anerkannten
Regierung zu behindern ihnen nicht die
Kontrolle über das ganze Land zu
überlassen und zu blockieren
gleichzeitig ist Libyen ölreiches Land
mit vielen Einnahmen durch die
Ölverkäufe das heißt das Land ist im
Grunde nicht arm doch die breite
Bevölkerung hat davon nicht profitiert
weil Korruption ein wesentlicher
Bestandteil der libischen Politik ist
auch um gerade in Ost Libyen und
gleichzeitig war natürlich in ostblumen
in der Vergangenheit vor allem die
russische wagnergruppe stark präsent
Stütze die dortige ostregierung und
sagte mit für die Stabilität im ganzen
Land
ja wir haben ja also ein Land was schon
vor dieser Katastrophe politisch sehr
instabil war jetzt noch zusätzlich durch
die Katastrophe geschwächtes und wir
haben es eben in den Beitrag auch schon
gesehen die Menschen sind natürlich
geschockt sie sind in Schockstarre aber
sie sind zunehmend auch sauer und wütend
über fehlende Hilfe und fehlende
Unterstützung in den letzten Jahren wenn
wir jetzt ein Stück in die Zukunft
gucken welche Auswirkungen kann diese
Katastrophe vielleicht mittelfristig für
das politische System im Land haben
also zuallererst geht es natürlich um
die humanitäre Lage derzeit das musst du
für gesagt werden dass die Leichen
geborgen werden können vermisste
gefunden und dann auch der Wiederaufbau
stattfinden kann und dann wird es in der
Tat darum gehen was bedeutet das für die
politische Zukunft dieses ohnehin
fragilen aber Geostrategie ist so
wichtigen Landes in Nordafrika am
Mittelmeer und in Europa direkt der
südlicher Nachbarschaft und es steht zu
vermuten dass die Bevölkerung aus Libyen
zunehmend auch kritisch gegenüber hafter
und seine ausregierung auftreten wird es
bleibt abzuwarten ob dieser Unmut sich
auch um transferieren wird in eine Unmut
gegen die beste Regierung aber es wird
sicher nach den Schuldigen gefragt
werden danach wieso so ein schreckliches
Ereignis geschehen konnte weshalb ich
frühzeitig gewarnt wurde und deshalb im
Allgemeinen die Bevölkerung in der nah
und den angrenzenden Gebieten seit
Jahren systematisch ver nachlässigt wird
ja vielleicht werden wir an anderer
Stelle zum späteren Zeitpunkt noch mal
darüber sprechen danke schön Erfolg dass
sie meine Fragen und die Fragen der
Community beantwortet haben schönen
Abend noch
einen schönen Abend
ja ich finde das waren wirklich ziemlich
eindrückliche Schilderungen gerade die
der beiden Helfer vor Ort und auch die
Bilder von golini die einen wirklich
mitnehmen wenn ihr da draußen den
Menschen in Libyen helfen wollt dann
könnt ihr das machen über das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe wenn
ihr spenden wollt ist hier die iban.de
400 600 100
400 600 das Stichwort ist ZDF Nothilfe
Libyen und weitere Infos dazu findet ihr
auch unter Spenden Punkt zdf.de
danke dass ihr heute eingeschaltet habt
wie es mit dieser flugkatastrophe weiter
geht's zum einen für die Menschen vor
Ort die unmittelbar betroffen sind aber
auch wie es politisch mit dem Land in
Zukunft weitergeht ich bin mir sicher
wir bei ZDF heute live bleiben dran ich
freue mich wenn ihr wieder einschaltet
und wünsche euch noch einen schönen
Abend